so far this year we've had warrior which
was like the rocky for MMA and now we
have Real Steel which is like The Karate
Kid of Rock'em Sock'em robots would you
like as a boxer Johnny was the top
contender number two in the world
then the fight game changed
real steals directed by Shawn Levy
that's the main reason I wasn't thinking
this movie would be that great he's
directed Cheaper by the Dozen 1 & 2 The
Pink Panther 1 & 2 & 19 Museum wanted to
real classic films as the credits for
this movie rolled I realize it's
produced by Robert Zemeckis and Steven
Spielberg how did I not know that stars
Hugh Jackman Evangeline Lilly Anthony
Mackie and a young kid who I don't know
it's a future time where robots are now
the fighters and humans don't really do
the fighting anymore
now everyone watches robots fighting and
Hugh Jackman and his son who he hasn't
really seen ever decide to go with this
this robot who's mainly only used for
sparring battles to try to use him in
bhau's to see if he can win sounds like
it could be a fun movie right it
actually is this ain't a video game this
is for real let's make some
I really actually had a lot of fun with
this movie I was really surprised I had
literally very low expectations going
into this film which may have helped a
bit one of the things that really helps
the movie for me is that it has a strong
emotional undercurrent it's not just the
the robots and the the fighting with
that it actually has a very strong
emotional side to the film where Hugh
Jackman doesn't really know his son at
all son doesn't know him but the one
thing they have in common is they both
really like this this whole world of
robot fighting and everything and so
through that they're able to build this
relationship and it's nice I mean it was
good it gave the film emotional weight
it actually touched me a little bit to
be honest and just need a little loan as
much as I like you dude you're a bad bet
brother give it up Charlie you got
nothing left as we know the recent trend
of action films is shaky-cam so on your
fake shaky cam everywhere I mean they
can't just film anything anymore
everything has to be like no one does
real stunts anymore everything is just
you know let's shake the camera and make
it look cool of course it never does not
here Shawn Levy actually directs the
action very well and it's a very
good-looking film I liked Hugh Jackman
in this movie I've always liked him but
he has not exactly been 100% consistent
with his films anyway he is always good
but his films not always and I like the
kid maybe the kid didn't know I mean
that's something that usually happens
with kids and sometimes I just get
really annoyed by kids but not in this
movie I liked him I liked his character
I like you Jackman's character they had
good chemistry
I liked also I really liked the robot
action it was actually kind of riveting
some of the matches never seen anything
like it before
can we get him a fight he's a sparring
bot built to take a lot of hits but
never dishing out any real punishment
his knee was audible
get him a fight I did have some problems
to the film here's some of the issues I
had it's very predictable to be honest
it's a completely predictable film and
so in a lot of ways you know what's
gonna come you know what's happening and
so it's not like it's gonna surprise you
that much it's just a really fun time
basically it's credits it's one of those
crowd-pleasing movies were just like
yeah you know just like or you get into
it the whole system of the robots and
how they work and how much AI is there
how much actual intelligence of some
kind is there you know what I mean never
really got into it's not really
explained you don't really know where
this came from how it started the time
period I would have liked to know more
about the whole technical aspect of how
the robots actually worked I know I've
done all kinds of wrong by this kit just
like to do one thing right
so essentially this is just a really fun
movie that that kids will like and that
adults can get into feel like boxing or
MMA or anything like that I think that
you will enjoy this movie more than the
average person because the the boxing
matches are actually really good and
towards the end I may have gotten a
little emotional maybe I need some steak
so I'm going to give Real Steel a b-plus
if you liked my review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stockman eyes